we went through the conflict in almost
every way and then we took out
key dates from the key places of the battles
that marked everyone we learned a
lot of
things we were passionate about it made us
want to pass it on to younger
generations  but in a more
approachable way as range support
indicates the ubisoft team one
really is a realistic game steeped
in history and can appeal to
players' feelings around those
fates in the first world war
that's  why is the game boy à what we
cols historique al fax one drop in game
sometimes you will have and into
dedicated to something you did in the
game with more colorized photos
from the apocalypse documentary series which
fits perfectly with the
color palette of the  game for example abandoned the
player finds himself in ypres in
belgium he is ready under the gas at this
time it is the first
gas attack on April 22 we offer players
to look  r what really happened
we actually worked on one side on the
text the historical content of the game with
the 1060 r the whole side on the photos
with apocalypse
we knew that a woman from the circus with
the  we will find what that we can bring
documentation historical sites work to
the game date
ubisoft as produced ligue 1